desde áfrica está hacia los musulmanes
de todo el mundo celebra en el final del
mes sagrado del ramadán pero el alza de
los precios de los alimentos básicos en
todo el mundo debido a la guerra de
ucrania puso en jaque la ruptura del
ayuno en sudáfrica estos voluntarios
preparan grandes ollas comunitarias
el propósito es tratar de aliviar el
sufrimiento y ayudar a los pobres y
alimentar a los hambrientos una
tradición que inició hace 40 años que
hace parte de la caridad uno de los
cinco pilares del islam
me siento agradecida porque sabes que
hay mucha gente que no tiene comida y de
este lado la pobreza es real estamos
realmente agradecidos
en pakistán las mujeres también acuden a
las mezquitas para las oraciones del eid
al-fitr y luego viene el posterior
banquete familiar su madre miraba
cheques hábitat breve que garza es
nuestra tradición que todos nuestros
parientes visiten la casa del hermano
mayor el día del eid nos sentamos y
comemos juntos
los rezos masivos del eid al-fitr se
vieron también en una de las mezquitas
más grandes de india donde la minoría
musulmana pudo volver a reunirse tras
más de dos años de pandemia
es una buena sensación porque hubo un
cierre durante los últimos dos años y no
tuvimos la oportunidad de ofrecer
oraciones
en cachemira la disputada región
musulmana controlada por nueva delhi las
autoridades hindúes no permitieron
oraciones colectivas masivas pero a
pesar las restricciones los fieles se
reunieron en el interior de los templos
hoy todos están felices podemos saludar
y abrazar a la gente ya que hay menos
miedo al cob y 19 es después de tres
años que la gente visita a sus
familiares en state
el inicio y el final del ramadán varía
dependiendo de la región pero están
marcados por el calendario lunar